нас в режимі такого дуже пришвидшеного я
би сказала це все вчили насичена
програма відповідно 40 днів ми проходили
теорію практично підготовку Ну І от
сьогодні по суті ми вже випускники які
отримали дозвіл керувати такими великими
класними пташками
Сьогодні у нас дорогі друзі Великий день
ми його чекали дуже-дуже довго тут перед
вами стоїть комплекс більш як на 45 млн
грн
кожен з вас точно знає бойові можливості
комплексів Посейдон
можу відверто сказати що настільки
потужний розсунутий технічно комплекс до
мене в руки потрапив перший раз Мені є з
чим порівнювати проблемні технічні
питання які виникали з комплексами
іншими тут вони вирішені Це набагато
покращить роботу аеророзвідки
коригування артилерії коригування
вогневого враження Ми дуже вдячні людям
які підійшли до рішення технічних питань
саме комплексно
це технічне рішення базування цього
Великого комплекса на вантажівки яка
дозволяє дістатися до місця зльоту
оперативно дозволяє вирішувати Таня
доставки технічне оснащення комплексу
такого нашим чертежам по нашим
забаганкам враховані всі найдрібніші
деталі які в процесі експлуатації ми на
них зауважували Тут є все для
вирішення пілотних завдань для виконання
бойових розпоряджень
які люди вітають
проти получився дуже непогано Тут є і
інвертор який забезпечує живлення тут є
генератор
дизельний підігрівач або в чистому полі
під морозом під дощем або сидиш тут в
тебе
звукоізоляція шумоізоляція світло
ізоляція Ми зробимо спеціальні
маскувальні сітки
Я відносно недавно військовослужбовець і
це по суті така перша велика пташка ти
покривала у моєму житті і в принципі
скажу вам якщо мозок працює і Хоч якийсь
навички є то ним не настільки важко
навчитися управляти Він достатньо
інтуїтивний борт і який правильно гарно
себе поводить в небі в нього хороша
камера в нього хороша стабілізація Він
дуже класно працює Під засобами
радіохвинної боротьби Ну і відповідно ну
вдається ним виконувати завдання
сьогодні це не просто проект фонда
Порошенка і справи громад а сьогодні до
цієї спільної роботи долучилися ще низка
благодійних організацій і наших бойових
побратимів ми передаємо комплекси і я
думаю що вже найближчими днями вони
будуть запущені в роботу бригади
артилерійської розвідки яка працює по
всьому фронту яка
посилить значно можливості української
арти битерусню мені особливо приємно
передати
комплекси разом зі справою громад
59-ї гайсинської бригади разом з Дем
сокирою Гудименка вітання тобі де наш
спільний проект і особливо приємна
передати танковій бригаді
спільна
з Владою Кривого Рога стосовно бойового
застосування цього літака Це військова
Таємниця Я думаю що узки будуть
неприємно здивовані практичним
застосуванням цих літаків